[Music]
you're probably gonna find out about it
anyway
so here's a little pre-emptive
truth-telling
there's no happy ending one two three
chef anthony bourdain ebony bourdain
anthony bourdain the renowned chef and
best-selling author of kitchen
confidential all the tv chefs are so
cuddly and adorable you know maybe i'm
the antidote or something
has a new program parts unknown one
minute i was standing next to a deep
fryer the next i was watching the sunset
over the sahara what am i doing here
nothing feels better than leaving home
the bittersweet curse
travel isn't always pretty
you go away
you learn
you get scarred marked
changed in the process
this is great this theater
i have a long history of this theater
yeah the first
um i was working as a journalist right
after i graduated from college in san
francisco
and um roger me
opened up in one screen in new york and
this theater
in la
and i convinced my roommate to drive
from san francisco to la to see a
matinee and then back to san francisco
wow
and uh
and it's part of what got me excited
about what documentary could do
yeah i remember when that film came out
it was a game changer yeah
um
like a wildly entertaining documentary
yeah who knew yeah
well here we are um
so
first of all congratulations on this
film i watched it again i saw it back
when it initially came out and watched
it again and it's it's so powerful and
so personal um but let me ask did you
ever meet anthony bourdain i'm curious i
never met him um
you know i'm friends i with david chang
and david cho
and i got to know them because i did a
show called ugly delicious with them
and
i got to know a lot of people in that
kind of food world
and people lucky peach magazine that was
this kind of great alt food magazine and
and everybody talked about uncle tony
the whole time and he was you know we
don't even talk about it but he did so
much to help so many other people he had
a
publishing imprint where he would
publish
writers he liked and emerging voices he
liked and he
when they were trying to get their
magazine off the ground you know he gave
them money he wrote articles for them
you know like he was just a total
saints and but literally he was uncle
tony to everybody
and um
and when he died
i saw
all of my friends go through this
incredible
grief
but still at that time i wasn't thinking
i was going to make a documentary about
it it was just
just this great sadness and me
i think what i felt personally was
here's somebody who's showing more of
the world
to the rest of the world than just about
anybody else on this planet and like he
was fighting the good fight and
what the fuck are we gonna do with adam
i mean he's like one of the
there's so little
kind of empathy going around these days
and just understanding of other cultures
that
um
it felt like a defeat in that way you
know and then when
cnn had this idea to make a film and
they came to me
you know my first reaction was
yes because
because i felt like he was kind of a
documentary filmmaker i felt like we
were on the same journey and i make
films about culture and
the stuff he was interested in was the
stuff i was interested in and and i felt
on an idea level that i was really
attracted to it
um
i had that as the second time i watched
the film i actually found myself
thinking about you and like
essentially what you just said like he
he was in his own way a documentary
filmmaker and so you're making a film
about someone in your
exact
you know
calling yeah i mean it's interesting i
got
just today i got an email from
a well-known documentary filmmaker
who had just watched the film last night
who just said
this film i know what it's like to be on
the road 250 days a year shooting right
and that this film actually
was
spoke to me in a way that i felt like it
was about my experience
and the kind of both the beauty and the
dislocation that happens with living a
life like that
um
and that was like i think actually the
email i got this morning was
the best review i got i mean it just
made me so happy yeah um
because it's interesting you know i've
made
making documentaries you tend to not
think of them as being
autobiographical
um but they all are in their own way you
know right which is interesting nobody
ever talks about this in documentary but
i think we all explore our own issues
um through other people's issues we're
attracted to stories because there are
things we're trying to work out too yeah
well
so in so much conversation around
documentary people immediately hone in
on the subject matter of the film of
course and also then the conversation
often goes to
you know what's the social impact of the
documentary all of which is great but i
want to take a moment to talk to you
about i'd love to hear you talk about
um kind of the artistry behind the film
and how you approach this in terms of
creating the film visually and um
like the visual composition how when you
started the film what were you thinking
in terms of
how you wanted to structure the film
visually how you wanted to shoot it um
editing techniques like you know the the
artistry of filmmaking
that suited this subject i mean that i
did kind of what i do
when i start films and i've made a lot
of music films
but
it's funny i was just thinking about it
it's kind of been dawning on me that
even the films i make that aren't about
music are
they have a lot of music in them you
know i made a film about mr rogers it
doesn't seem to be about music but he
was
a music major in college he wrote 200
songs he was an amazing piano player
and there was a musicality to it and
tony was a huge music fan
huge and one of the first things i did
was start collecting any song he ever
mentioned or used
anywhere
and by the end of the film i had a
21-hour playlist
of every song wow which i put it up on
spotify so if you want to like it's the
best jukebox ever
i'm assuming road runner the jonathan
richmond jonathan richmond song was on
there yeah and that was
it was also one of those when i heard
that song
i said well that should be the title in
the movie and this is before we made the
movie
wow you know one of those
i second guessed myself for a year and a
half but
i couldn't come up with anything better
and knowing
how he loved that song that it was this
massachusetts
you know and yeah kind of the same
generation as tony in many ways and like
and what that song means and then
um
you know do you know who grail marcus is
yeah
so he had written a book called lipstick
traces that came out the summer i
graduated from college the summer the
year i saw mike uh roger me
and lipstick traces has a whole chapter
about that song and kind of all the
layers of it and what it means
um and then grail sent me an email a
couple weeks ago talking about
roadrunner and how much he loved it and
i was able to say to him had you not
written that book i don't know if i
would have called this movie roadrunner
i mean it connected me to that song in a
deeper way
so all these just
things from my life that keep circling
back again in a way that to me feels
personal but that nobody else would ever
know um but so all to answer your
question
it was the music i went back and watched
he he different times people asked him
his favorite movies or he put a list of
his 10 favorite movies or whatever and i
watched everything
i went back and reread you know
um joseph conrad and graham greene and
hunter thompson and all the kind of
his favorite writers and
just to kind of get and part of it is
he had awesome taste yeah like it wasn't
a
struggle to kind of
go into that and kind of take it in
um
and just to kind of get a feel for who
he was in that way and and kind of what
would inform the film
um
and virtually every song in the movie
comes from tony's playlist except for
maybe one or two
um
and then you know deciding to shoot all
the interviews with people sitting at a
table
you know like we're breaking bread in a
way
but the other thing was just
that it could never be a greatest hits
album
you know that
would be really easy
to be like oh you know remember that
story from kitchen confidential or
remember that episode or remember this
thing or you know this great you know
his sidekick from here or whatever and i
was like i
it's not about that at all it's just
trying to
find who this guy is psychologically and
what was motivating him through his life
and so
we had to be really
focused on what the film was going to be
because we had 20 000 hours of footage
which is an insane amount of footage
and so just the manpower to go through
we didn't end up even going through all
20 000 hours
we went through about 12 000 hours
and part of it is not all 20 000 hours
or a lot of it is duplicate footage or
there were definitely a number of
episodes he did that
his his crew was like there's always
like one episode a year where he tony
just wanted to do an episode on a beach
it was like his vacation episode right
you know where he was phoning it in
um
so you know and we even looked at a bit
of that but
there was just so much but then once it
became apparent then i found this
photographer who had begun shooting a
documentary about tony
right at the moment of publication of
kitchen confidential so all that early
footage
in the film comes from this guy dimitri
uh
tamikan i think
who
shot for a year he shot 60 hours he
never finished the film and he had it in
a box
and
getting that footage and transferring it
and looking at it and i was like oh my
god this is
the beginning of the film and then i
very quickly realized
it could be
immersive like in that way
you know they're barely
they're only a couple of you know like
two photographs in the whole film like
it's really uh i wanted to make it a
right active film you know and i think
i mean we had so many rules about about
it but i think one thing i was really
trying to correct for was it's very easy
in the wake of somebody's death
particularly a suicide
like this that's traumatic to
see everything backwards through the
filter of that
and so
when we started
uh eileen meyer one of my editors
um i said to her we're going to start at
the beginning
and we're not going to think about what
happens to tony
at least for the next four months
literally like i don't want you to look
at those parts of the interviews i don't
really look at archive like we're just
gonna go from the beginning because
that's how you live you know
you know you don't read it backwards
right you leave it forwards
and we cut the first 40 minutes
like that wow um you know we revised it
and everything but
it was just this sense of
excitement and possibility and naivete
and all these things that he had i mean
those scenes of him signing books for
kitchen confidential he's so like goofy
and boyish and like
naive yeah so it's just that like
irrepressible energy
and it was so great to see that like
i've never really seen that yeah before
you know and even somebody has kind of
has such a kind of a uh a world-weary
persona
even in kitchen confidential he does
he's already been a junkie at that point
right i mean he had been yeah
but he sure is kind of
excited little boy when all this stuff
is happening yeah you know and it was
such an i mean what
it was one of those decisions at the
beginning rather than trying to tell his
story from
birth to death
that
the story that was more interesting to
me was somebody who in middle age
is suddenly given a life-changing
success and opportunity
and does that
make him happy does that fix him in a
way right it's that's so unusual i mean
he was 43 when kitchen confidential was
published
wow and to see
i mean if you go back and reread kitchen
confidential
there is such a sense
of
having lived his life and his story is
over
and there's even this passage in kitchen
confidential where he talks about
um
basically saying if
he because it's tony he has this
colorful metaphor he says you know if i
if i'm
walking across the street and an ice
cream truck hits me
and i'm there lying in the street with a
bumper sticking out of my head and my
dying words you know you know what am i
going to think about he says i'm not
going to think about
opportunities i didn't have or places i
didn't go or foods i didn't eat or women
i didn't sleep with
you know it's like i'm not going to
regret any of that i'm just going to
regret
the
disappointment and pain i left in
the lives of people i left behind
you know he wrote that when he was 42.
wow
um
i just was well i mean you sort of
answered the next question i was going
to ask which is the framing of the film
you start with kitchen confidential so
you don't get that whole preamble of his
early life and boyhood and
um
and i'm curious like how you came to the
decision to start where you did but also
to end where you did i mean obviously
there's a natural ending he committed
suicide
but you go beyond that there's i mean to
me the most
i found the whole film moving but that
end part where you see his friends
talking and just the palpable grief that
they still feel
like
his story lives on beyond him and the
impact it had on on
the people in his life so i'm just
curious how did you determine like
where does this start and where do i end
because part of it is in in going back
and rereading kitchen confidential
i feel like that book
does it so well
it tells that i mean i kind of feel like
if you really want to understand tony
read kitchen potential and watch the
documentary yeah you know and it's not
that there's anything
contradictory about those two tellings
but you'll
you get his voice and then you get kind
of what happened to him when he
wasn't writing about himself in the same
way
um and whenever i tried to kind of get
more and you know and i played with it
and i interviewed some of the chefs who
were
from that part of his life
but it started to feel like a greatest
hits album like oh remember that great
story if you get your confidential well
here's somebody telling you that story
with no footage and no photos and
it just tonally everything about it was
just very different yeah and
and also you know we're trying to
condense
you know i feel like my job is
i talk about essentializing you know
that
you know when you're making a
documentary you're not writing a book
it's so reductive you know and you're
not so you're really just trying to kind
of have
some kind of an understanding or of an
essence of a person
rather than a
a to z like that's what wikipedia is for
right you know this is trying to just
understand what makes a person tick
and
so starting and that was kind of what
got me starting the film where we
started
and then the experience of making the
film the thing i didn't fully realize
when i
first began the film was how much i was
making a film about suicide
and my experience of making the film was
one of
intense grief
you know when i
sat down with the people in the film and
i
actually i think there are 18 people in
the film but i interviewed almost twice
that many
and that
and that's because i wanted
the viewer to actually build a
relationship with everybody in the film
and i'd never done this before where i
introduce everybody in the film so
hopefully you actually understand
everybody's connection to tony
so that when he dies
you feel
the grief because you know these people
yeah and it was my experience in making
the film like i loved the people i got
to know from tony's world yeah and
they've become friends of mine and i
just
saw two of them last week when i was in
new york and
and they're like whether or not you like
it morgan you're now part of tony's crew
you know yeah it's like this
um
you know um
club of people who've been through the
shit i guess
could you talk a bit about how i was
really curious those interviews
right we've all seen lots of
documentaries with talking head
interviews in the film this is not what
this was these were
is used they're seated at tables
but more than that they're they like i'm
curious how what i'd love to hear you
talk about how you shot them like
in in some detail like like how did you
establish the mood
the
the sense of the set to get them to
because they open up so much
and are so personal to and one thing i
love in the film is you have
throughout it's it's short moments but
you you'll hold on someone's face when
they're not talking like before they
speak and there's just so much happen
like
they don't need to say anything in that
moment like with the shots that you get
you see this play of emotion whether
it's grief or joy or anger whatever's
going on like
it feels so i'm just curious like what
the what the set was like how you were
like i mean these were the these are the
longest hardest interviews i've ever
done for a documentary and like i've
been doing documentaries for a long time
and i've done a lot of interviews i love
doing interviews
um but these were not interviews they
were therapy sessions right and
you know i think otavio says in the film
that you know this is the last time
she's ever gonna talk publicly about it
i think there were right like six people
said that to me
in making the film
um just that it was the time
to talk about it and that even people
so like chris and lydia the two
producers who had started his production
company with him
um
in the wake of his death it was like
them trying to go into panic mode and
figure out what was going to happen with
their company and their lives and
everything and
and when i sat down to talk to them a
year and a half later
lydia was the first interview i did and
chris was the last interview i did
and lydia
said
chris and i have never talked about this
we're married we work with tony for 20
years wow and we've never like had to
sit down and say
how are you processing this what do you
think and so
i think also with suicide that's very
common because
it's such a fucked up thing because it's
tied up with feelings of guilt what
should i have done i experienced a lot
of people saying that and feeling
different versions of
you know guilt and anger and
um
but people don't feel like they have
permission to talk about their grief
in some particularly around suicide
and so when i showed up and i was like
let's just
talk about it that those conversations
became
hopefully for them therapeutic you know
they were intense but in a way that i
felt
honored that they were
opening up like that and many of the
people
i talked to before him often would have
a meal with them beforehand
not to talk about tony much but just to
like
right
so i wasn't a stranger yeah you know
and
you know and i think my way of doing
interviews is
like we're just having a conversation
and at some point they're filming
and they're and we're going for hours
you know these were long for me long
interviews so they were i know maybe
averaging three hours
i'm curious were you seated at the table
across from them so you were like right
there i was not you weren't back with
the cameras or in the village you're
just sitting there and
i mean also you know
it's part of how i like to do interviews
which is like i had a piece of paper
but i never looked
at paper i never broke eye contact with
people yeah talking to them for three
hours you know it was and then
it was like you just tell me and i may
not get what everything i need but
that's it's more important for me to be
engaged with you and us just to have the
most real conversation we can have yeah
and then
and then
there's just like a moment where it
feels like okay
we've reached some place and like
it just it's it's over like i don't want
to keep fishing for more stuff like yeah
it's lived its life and like the
interview is done
um
and did you in the it might say you had
two cameras yeah through most of that
okay yeah i mean it's you know
a lot of times people like talking heads
you know there's a lot of kind of
eye rolling about talking head
documentaries but
um
and even other documentary which are
great you know but a documentary like i
know amy or something which is a great
documentary but no talking heads just
interviews audio interviews but to me
like
i just love people's
faces
you know um
i mean film like one should be my
neighbor i ended the whole movie on a
montage of people's faces not talking oh
i think so and it's like i yeah
to me that's how i connect to people and
feel
through them
so
i mean
i mean yeah it definitely comes during
the film i mean i'm thinking of david
chang and david cho and
his producers like yeah you it's the
faces
that reveal their history with him no
matter what they're saying yeah and i i
think if i'd made this film
you know five years from now
it wouldn't be quite the same film i
mean i think the film is also a
reflection of my experience of making
the film which was
grief you know and all those other
emotions but
it was just raw
you know and so
you know i've seen documentaries that
deal with
suicide where
you know you kind of
they explain why somebody kills himself
and then the film's over but you don't
deal
with what it left behind afterwards
and i think my experience of what was
left behind afterwards was so profoundly
strong
that i felt like i had to honor that
by
just
telling that part of the story
you know just because in terms of the
suicide of it i mean i think part of
tony
felt that
you know there's the stupid live fast
die young kind of there's something
romantic about suicide
tony
was always
interested in suicide i mean he could
tell you every famous person that ever
killed themselves and how like he joked
about it i mean i think we
have one or two examples but there were
many many many examples of him joking
about it
um
and
that's bullshit
right you know it just is
you know and i think
that's the thing
[Music]
that
i at least wanted to reflect not to
diminish from
his pain or what he was going through
but
to give equal weight to
the pain
it left that there's nothing cool about
it you at least know that yeah
that there's nothing cool about leaving
a 12 year old daughter behind
you know there's just
the the kind of devastation you know and
and uh
yeah
and now
you know almost four years later it's uh
i mean i think people
you know i mean
i'm happy to see how much better
everybody is doing
you know and in a way i feel like the
film was not only an active therapy for
them and active therapy for me
hopefully it was some kind of an active
therapy for the people that saw the film
because when i talked about this film in
the beginning and i would tell people i
was making a film about anthony bourdain
often i would get this reaction like
um
oh my god i loved him i loved that show
but so sad what happened i just i i
can't even i can't even think about him
i can't watch him i can't you know like
it was such a disconnect for people that
i think people just wanted to block him
out
because it was just all unprocessed like
i don't know what to make of that it was
just right horrible so
this might sound crazy i i don't know
but to me so on the one hand he was an
extr clearly an extraordinary individual
right i mean he was enormously talented
and charismatic and
an unusual person but on the other hand
as i was watching the film
i do think i mean to your point
of the audience reaction
in some way i think a lot of people
identify with him like i i do and not
that i'm in anthony bourdain but there's
a quality that he has and a outlook on
the world that i think is common to a
lot of people
and so
you know and a kind of darkness and
attractive attractedness to that sort of
you know
dark elements of life and
to see where the film goes and his
suicide and how it affects people
resonates like you you take it in
personally like yeah this isn't just
some extraordinary guy who killed
himself this could be me like this could
be one of my friends this is like
these are people i understand and care
about and like it
it i think it resonates in that way
for a lot of people who see the film i
think that's part of the incongruity of
his death that people like how could
this guy who was so smart and had i mean
right you know after he died
dave chappelle
did his first netflix special if you
remember this
and he came out the first joke first
thing he says in his first netflix
special is you know
a joke where he says essentially anthony
bourdain
had the best life ever could do go
anywhere saw the world and that dude
killed himself you know so what hope is
there for the rest of us
right and
i think
that was what a lot of people were
thinking it's like how the hell could
this person that had the perfect life
kill themselves and of course
you know mental health and all those
other things you know it's
you know that's it's a facile for us to
think that way and it's good to remind
ourselves that people are way more
complicated than what you see on the
surface
um
and tony i mean the thing that i
struggle with you know somebody
had written a new yorker profile of tony
and they
being the new yorker they said uh
the tony was a apollonian described
disguised as a dionysian
very new yorker
um but when i unpacked that
you know it's like tony was like an
uptight anal guy
who thought he was keith richards
right
that's essentially what that means yeah
he was hyper punctual he was you know
very responsible
um but he
loved iggy and keith and the guys who
were the quintessential
dionysian figures you know for like the
attic rock and roll guys that live
forever and like
um but it to me it always seemed like
tony wasn't really that he just
admired it but that wasn't really in his
bones and i think
at times he tried
to go i mean he became a junkie you know
in a way that he even says was like
fully romantic the idea of he knew
exactly what he was signing up for yeah
right um
and i think he often did like there was
this sense of like
well this isn't working something in my
life isn't working i'm just gonna
try and blow it up in a different way
and kind of
with you know drugs or relationships or
whatever you know that it was
something that to me i still don't
fully it just doesn't seem him
because he wasn't right he was too
uptight except but again you know in a
you know with
the right circumstances or drugs or
mental health that you know people
aren't themselves you know and i
i think tony
was certainly not himself when he killed
himself
um
i mean the day he killed himself he was
giving notes on edits and making lunch
plans for the following week
wow i mean it was not somebody who was
signaling that they were going to kill
themselves right
you know i just think it was a bad
moment
yeah you know that's all it takes
um i want to ask you so you said there's
20 20 000 hours of archival footage
which i believe and i mean you did an
amazing job i don't know what uh
how many hours you looked at but the the
what you've assembled here is incredible
in terms of the archival stuff and i did
i want to ask you i mean
um
well one question
i'm sure it comes from different sources
a lot of it comes from the shows but
there was some footage there that seemed
very personal and i was like what is
this from like with the scene when he's
lying on the couch like he's obviously
performing for camera on almost all of
it but like when he's doing the therapy
thing
was that part of a show and since you
mentioned iggy there's a great scene
between him and iggy where he talks
about how the greatest thing is
being loved which is like
exactly what tony needed yeah but the
look on tony's face when he hears it is
like i don't think tony's feeling it
like
there's like a sadness in his reaction
there were a lot of things like the
the therapy session
you know it was a buenos aires episode
and um i guess more people were in
psychotherapy in argentina than any
other country on the planet so they
thought it would be fun to go
have tony go to do therapy
um
and so they set it up
and
they shot for 90 minutes like it starts
kind of is him doing shtick and he's
like uh if i see have one more bad
hamburger an airport i'm gonna you know
jump off a building and like he's kind
of just doing his shtick and then at a
certain point you know
it
he gets much more real and i'm not
saying it it's not at all performative
um
but
you know after 90 minutes it was like i
felt like he was really talking about
real i know he was talking about real
things and and something else he did in
um when they would shoot his crew talked
about this that when he would sit down
with people he would often
talk about him his own like worst
moments like from the beginning or his
own problems i mean
i talked to david simon who said that uh
the first thing tony said to him was oh
you're from baltimore you know i tried
to score heroin in baltimore and
couldn't
to which david simon said you must have
been a horrible junkie then because it's
everywhere
um
wow
but i think
so what his crew said would they would
sit down and for the first 20 minutes
tony would go on about himself and talk
while the cameras are wrong while the
cameras are rolling and the crew is
thinking come on we're already on to the
deep in the entree you know like we've
gone through appetizers and like
and then
he would shut up and people would
open up
because tony had opened up to them yeah
but they never used that footage right
you know
um
but you did i mean it's amazing the the
outtakes and what's what's most
remarkable to me about the the film with
the in terms of the archival footage is
how you build
his character was the same
i mean he obviously changed as he aged
but his character was his character but
through the archival footage i got this
clear sense of there's a progression
from
that boyish
happy energy even with the darkness
already there from kitchen confidential
progressing through like
what happened in lebanon and the shift
there and then libya and
you know
like there's a progression of
maturity in a way not just going darker
but like he's becoming
right his perspective on the world is
changing and his perspective on the
value of his work is changing and you
really capture that through the film and
then of course up into
what happened at the end of his life i
think he was both
i mean all these progressions happening
i think he's becoming both more
worldly and then becoming kind of world
weary in a way right and
i feel like he
saw
so much
suffering i guess and difficult
the kind of intractability of how
fucked up so much of this world is that
i think he became less optimistic
you know just
you know people aren't right not many
people see as much of the world as he
saw very very very few people do
um i mean the fact that he became i said
agoraphobic
yeah was so i think it started to take a
kind of a psychological toll on him
too
you know because he was
very empathetic and he really felt
these things he wasn't just
you know
showing up and
talking about food and leaving right
like he was invested and so
i think there was a certain kind of like
yeah just
being
it's not even burnt out it's just kind
of almost more more kind of existential
feeling of
you know
if this isn't
bringing me the joy it used to bring me
then what is there you know because it
brought him so much joy to have that
experience of having yeah everything
open up that way
um
yeah and it was hard and you know it's
it's not
i mean obviously you know
was addicted to work
um
you know and workaholism is like the
last socially acceptable addiction in
this country
you know so
um
and it worked for him for a long time
until it didn't
and i think that's part of what he was
wrestling with too at the end it's like
it's it wasn't enough anymore
so i'm sure there were many of these
moments for you but when you were in the
process of going through all that
archival footage were there moments
where
there's i mean there's so much good
stuff but were there moments where you
saw a clip that just was like
electrified you were like this these
hidden nuggets were like oh my god this
is going to be this is we did not expect
to get this and this is going in the
film
yeah it's
um i mean
many of them are in the film you know
it's like
there's a quick shot of
i don't know if you can tell what it is
there's just this
tony this old lady walks up to tony
while he's standing there and takes his
hand this like 95 year old lady
you know doesn't speak english and just
like holds his hand
you know and tony it's just like this
amazing
um
kind of vulnerable tony
you know and then there was a moment of
him dancing with his shirt off and
everything and
and when i was hanging out with one of
his directors he's like oh tony never
would have left lettuce use that footage
because he just was so self-conscious
about
you know
when to be cool or whatever and like
um
and so
you know tony
you know was very prescriptive about
what he wanted to do on camera in the
show
and i think we wanted to treat the
footage as verite footage it's like
found footage and trying to explore
these real moments
i mean there was another scene we had
that we
that just
ended up not fitting but
where he um he gets a tattoo
in uh
i think he's in miami
and he gets a tattoo that says um
in ancient greek it says i believe in
nothing
um
which sounds kind of cool like kind of
zen or buddhist you know that
you know i'm i'm uncertain of everything
you know it's translated different ways
you know and
if you're 60
and you're truly uncertain of everything
then you're lost
and there was something about
tony being this searcher character
yeah that if you're and searching's
great being curious is great being
out in the world is great
but if you do it to that extent
you're really running away from
something like you don't know where you
are
if you're
a profound searcher
which and if you really don't believe in
anything if you don't believe in the
love of people around you you know if
you don't believe in
um
what's true and right you know like if
you really doubt everything
then that's
especially at that age you know it's one
thing if you're a teenager but at that
age there's something
sad about that to me i mean in the film
i felt the moment when he
separates her divorces from otavia felt
like a real turn like people get
divorced all the time but like in the
film it feels like a real
something in him where he he's becoming
unmoored
not just from her but from you know
family and the bonds of i mean i think
his way of dealing with it was
um
i tried to be normal it didn't work out
right right
i mean really you know
so
when he got divorced
he started smoking again he started
drinking a lot more
he started doing more soft drugs
his voice got heavier
his leather jacket came back
you know i mean it was you we heard it
you could hear it in
just listening to his voice
you know
how different it was
um yeah it was like
some version of the old tony but
you know
that
with kind of less a more weary yeah more
weary version of it
and i think everybody
saw how troubling that was at the time
and i think eventually he did i mean he
finally went into therapy for the first
time in his life
just about two and a half months before
he died
and so i think he was aware
that things weren't going well
he just didn't have the tools to deal
with
it i have one last question which is um
i'm curious since the film came out
um i'm assuming a lot of people in the
film and in tony's life have seen it i'm
just curious like what anything you care
to share what you've heard back like how
is the film resonating for them and
are you getting surprising reactions
from people or
i've gotten
so many great
reactions i mean i
you know i think um
i mean people like
i mean i don't think i'm telling tales
out of school but like
like eric repaired did not want to do an
interview
um and
and i had a long talk with him
as to why
i thought he should talk and why it was
sensitive to
what
his unique position because he was there
with tony
when tony died
you know in staying in the same hotel
and he
found tony's body with the police
and
um
and he
really kind of grilled me
and we had a long talk and then um and
then he agreed to do the interview
and then when he saw the film he sent me
an email he was like
you fucking did it like you
tony would be so proud of this
and i you know it's like things like
that that i'm like
yeah you know
it's for you know i feel like it
it's funny because in the beginning i
felt in the very beginning i felt like
i'm making this film for tony
in a way like he's my audience
because i want him to see
all the dna of the music and the film
and all the energy and all this stuff
and then at a certain point as i was
making the film i was like
i'm actually making it for the people in
tony's life
you know it became it turned at a
certain point
because there's part of the story that
tony shouldn't like
um
yeah and
and i feel
you know
i feel good about that you know i i
you know you never
you know
we're all insecure artists we don't say
i nailed it you know but at least i felt
like
i
what i can say is like we worked
so hard on this film
and we're so intentional about
everything
that
i felt like we
we didn't want to ever feel like we
hadn't really thought through everything
in every edit um
and so you know i felt like we did the
best we could do and that's all you can
do
um including my insanely amazing editors
uh aaron wickenden and eileen meyer
amazing
and we all just
and we also edited this whole thing in
covid which was insane
um
but we couldn't go anywhere except with
tony
you know it was actually kind of an
amazing experience
to be traveling the world yeah yeah yeah
as we're making this film more all just
stuck you know by ourselves
um
were you adding to together in one room
or it was remote and you guys were
communicating over i mean
two or three months of editing eileen
and i were together
and then coveted hit and then
we were
now there are all these software
programs
where you can
[Music]
i could be looking at our edit screen
and we could be talking and you know
yeah it kind of sucks but it works and
like
and then aaron came in
and he was in chicago
you know and so we
it was just one of those
things it was very unusual and i'd
actually shot
pretty much the whole film before kovid
except for
two interviews
um otavia and helen
helen joe
two very important interviews
um
sorry was helen the crew member yeah
yeah she's amazing yeah she's great
and i had um
i had many meal i had at least two meals
with each of them beforehand like i'd
actually spent a lot of time with them
so it wasn't like i was a stranger and i
just and this was like the fir you know
in early cove and i was like i just i
can't finish this film without these two
interviews
you know
and so i
i did it and i was here in la and they
were in new york and i had a crew in new
york and
i did them by zoom oh my god
which was you know
hard and had i not
spent a lot of time with them beforehand
um
i don't know if i could have done that
um but it was just
and i think it worked
i think i mean
you can't tell no no you can't tell but
um
you know i wouldn't like to do that i
mean yeah yeah i wow i would have gotten
on a plane to do it but
nobody would have let me right right
yeah
well morgan thank you so much
congratulations on the film thank you so
much
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]